die menschheit muss ich von einer
vorstellung verabschieden wir schreiben
hier in unserem sonnensystem ruhig durch
das weltall und alles ist stabil und
sicher
das gegenteil ist der fall nicht nur
aktien kometen planetoiden und
kleinplaneten rahmen durch unser
sonnensystem und können auf der erde
einschlagen sondern auch im größeren
maßstab ist ganz schön bewegung im
universum die verschiedenen sternsysteme
ruhen nämlich nicht sondern quasi eben
auch mit einem affenzahn durch das
weltall und rohen sich gegenseitig zu
zerstören und hier im sonnensystem ist
die bedrohung in astronomischen
maßstäben schon wer nach der stern gysi
110 steuert auf unser sonnensystem zu
der wird uns gefährlicher als bisher
gedacht jetzt in science fiction
herzlich willkommen
er hatte schon in einem der letzten
videos die sonne ist nicht allein
entstanden sondern als zwillings stern
und nehme mit der zwilling unserer sonne
streift unser sonnensystem
höchstwahrscheinlich alle 26 millionen
jahre und das hat dramatische
konsequenzen dabei bringt er in die orte
wolke rund um unser sonnensystem ein und
wirbel jährige recht auf damit werden
tausende und abertausende gesteins staub
und eisbrocken richtung erde geschickt
und zahlreiche davon könnten dann auch
hier einschlagen
eine der folgen in der vergangenheit war
demnach das aussterben der dinosaurier
in 15 millionen jahren könnte es wieder
so weit sein so hat solches szenario und
das mit viel größerer gewissheit ist die
kollision unseres sonnensystems
mitglieds 710 zum jahr 2010 ist das
eigentlich klar damals konnten die daten
vom esa-satelliten epa kopf und exakter
ausgewertet werden und man stets auf die
410 und seinen kollisionskurs
doch es wird noch schlimmer kommen die
esa hat nämlich einen weiteren
satelliten ins all geschickt gaia
sammelt die daten von stern bewegungen
deutlich exakter inzwischen hat er die
daten von einer milliarde sterne
gesammelt und auch 410 war dabei mit
werft die und j ducati von der adam
mickiewicz universität posen polen haben
diese daten jetzt genau analysiert und
wind auf ein wirklich katastrophale
szenario gestoßen bisher gingen
astronomen astronomen von einer
maximalen annäherung von einem lichtjahr
aus doch gesehen wird viel dichter an
uns vorbei schrammten nur 77 tage also
fünfmal mehr wird sich der stern unserem
sonnensystem nähern damit werden die
auswirkungen deutlich drastischer sein
als bisher angenommen ein regen vom
kleinen planeten kometen und allem
anderen material aus der ortenburg ins
innere des sonnensystems wird die folge
sein anregen
der wahrscheinlich mehrere millionen
jahre andauern wird das risiko dass ein
größerer meteorit auf der erde
einschlagen wird ist ein extrem hoch und
ein damit verbundenes machens werben ist
wahrscheinlich ein trost das wird noch
135 millionen jahre dauern
eine herausforderung unsere nachfahren
müssen dann nicht nur die erde sondern
unser sonnensystem verlassen
abend um diesen bombardement zu entgehen
wie wir und gegenaktionen einschläge
schützen oder auch nicht damit geht es
hier im video aktuellen betonen die erde
weiter einfach draufklicken und wenn er
auch in zukunft nichts zum thema
verpassen worden da gibt es immer wieder
neues drückt mir hier ein abo aufs auge
und vergesst nicht den auf die glocke
bis dann bleibt dran